[Música]
la publicidad de nicaragua detuvo a seis
líderes estudiantiles y campesinos entre
ellos medardo mairena quien se convierte
así en el sexto opositor aspirante a la
presidencia en ser arrestado por las
autoridades minando aún más la
credibilidad del gobierno de daniel
ortega y de su intención de un proceso
electoral transparente el próximo mes de
noviembre
en la segunda entrega de nuestra serie
de reportajes dedicados a aquellos que
se han recuperado del hobby 19 les
contamos la historia del profesor marc
soy él quien padeció la enfermedad fue
internado en el mismo hospital para el
que trabajo hoy se ha recuperado sigue
luchando en la primera fila contra el
coronavirus
con todo el glamour y los son rostros
más destacados de la industria
cinematográfica mundial fue inaugurada
la versión número 74 del festival
internacional de cine de cannes 24
películas participan por la disputada
palma de oro en una versión que cuenta
con estrictas medidas de bioseguridad
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a comenzar en
centroamérica ya son 6 los aspirantes a
la presidencia de nicaragua arrestados
por las autoridades que se unen así a un
total de 25 personas detenidas en las
últimas semanas el gobierno del
presidente daniel ortega los acusa desde
el lavado de dinero hasta traición a la
patria desde bruselas la unión europea
advirtió de nuevas sanciones para
nicaragua al tiempo que también exigió
la liberación de los opositores jorge
hurtado nos cuenta más en el siguiente
informe
en nicaragua la cacería contra
opositores se intensifica previo a las
elecciones de noviembre el gobierno que
lidera daniel ortega arrestó a otros
seis líderes sociales entre ellos el
sexto aspirante presidencial y dos
líderes universitarios que dejaron
mensajes como estos
es momento de continuar la dictadura
quiere acabar con la esperanza
debemos seguir juntos esta lucha por la
libertad del pueblo nicaragüense minuto
la unión europea y otros países del
mundo condenaron los arrestos y
advirtieron de nuevas sanciones pero
ortega que busca su cuarta reelección ha
dicho estar firme para mantener en
prisión a más de 25 opositores que los
acusa por delitos como traición a la
patria y lavado de dinero no estamos
jugando candidato
aquí se está juzgando
a criminales que han atentado contra el
país contra la seguridad del país
pese al arresto de las figuras más
relevantes de la oposición el único
partido autorizado en participar en las
elecciones insiste en continuar en la
contienda
hay que seguir no importa lo que nos
pase tendrán que detener a 6 millones de
nicaragüenses pero yo creo que eso
obviamente va a ser imposible porque
aquí todos estamos dispuestos a seguir
adelante en las calles nadie se atreve a
protestar por el temor a terminar en
prisión los únicos que alzan la voz son
los familiares de estos líderes que
piden sean liberados y denuncian que las
autoridades no permiten verlos ni
acceder a un abogado independiente
nicaragua se vacía progresivamente de
sus disidentes periodistas y defensores
unos en prisión y otros en exilio todos
preguntándose quién será el próximo en
prisión
en colombia por primera vez la
jurisdicción especial para la paz imputó
a diez militares y un civil por la
ejecución de 120 personas y la
desaparición forzada de otras 24 en
hechos ocurridos en la frontera
colombo-venezolana entre los años 2007 y
2008 la magistrada catalina díaz afirmó
que la participación de los sindicados
fue determinante en el asesinato de más
de este centenar de personas que estaban
en total estado de indefensión y que
fueron presentadas como bajas de combate
para emplear las cifras oficiales
la magistrada díaz señaló que la
evidencia indica que los acusados son
responsables de crímenes de guerra
homicidio crímenes de lesa humanidad y
desaparición todos realizados de manera
sistemática se trató de un patrón de
macro criminalidad es decir la
repetición de por lo menos 120
asesinatos durante dos años en un mismo
territorio por un mismo grupo de
personas asociados en una organización
criminal
y siguiendo un mismo modus operandi la
sala de reconocimiento les imputó el
crimen de guerra de homicidio en persona
protegida y crímenes de lesa humanidad
de asesinato y desaparición forzada ante
el ataque generalizado y sistemático
contra la población civil en otros temas
el gobierno de eeuu anunció la donación
a guatemala de 1.5 millones de dosis de
la vacuna contra el cob y 19 de la
farmacéutica moderna el país
centroamericano se convierte así en la
octava nación de américa latina en
recibir una de estas donaciones de
vacunas que hacen parte de los 80
millones de dosis que el propio
presidente estadounidense joe biden
anunció que compartiría con otros países
20 millones de estas dosis solamente
para américa latina y para la región del
caribe
y debido al aumento de los casos y el de
las hospitalizaciones hasta en un 33% en
los últimos 10 días las autoridades de
la comunidad autónoma de cataluña en
españa anunciaron el cierre del ocio
nocturno a partir de este fin de semana
la generalitat de barcelona decidió
tomar esta medida que comienza a partir
del viernes por espacio de 15 días para
frenar el auge de contagios de kobe 19
particularmente entre los jóvenes
también desde el gobierno autónomo
reclamaron a las autoridades centrales
en madrid la capital que restablezca el
uso obligatorio de las mascarillas en el
exterior a nivel nacional
y en nuestra serie de reportajes
especiales dedicados a todos aquellos
que se han recuperado del cobi 19 en
nuestra segunda entrega vamos a ir hasta
el hospital de moss en donde encontramos
al profesor maxwell quien hace un año
padeció la enfermedad incluso estuvo
internado en el mismo hospital en el que
trabaja hoy en día ya completamente
recuperado sigue en la primera línea de
lucha contra el coronavirus veamos
el profesor sobre el se volvió de nuevo
el jefe de servicio dinámico que era
antes de la enfermedad
nos habíamos reunido hace más de un año
en su unidad de tratamiento del dolor
ver transformada entonces en una unidad
como estaba hospitalizado en su propio
servicio usted sabe la cantidad de
muertos o que haya la velocidad del
espacio porque ahora salvamos a la gente
y no solamente no le sube las patologías
que aparecerán otra vez
después de su entrevista fui transferido
a la unidad de reanimación de cuidados
intensivos en el hospital henri mondor
debido a mi degradación respiratoria de
el trabajo de las unidades médicas como
la del profesor sobre él era menos
mediatizado que el de los servicios de
reanimación un trabajo sin embargo
primordial en el marco de la atención a
los pacientes hobbits y el trabajo de
los equipos médicos era apreciar bien a
los pacientes bien apreciados por su
evolución y crear una reacción muy
rápida ancash y muy eficaz que permita
hacer pasar las etapas sin irse a
reanimación sopas de palabras
la dedicación total de los médicos
durante la pandemia tuvo consecuencias y
desafortunadamente hubo mucha licencia
por enfermedad
diría que la crisis del cobi precipitó
su partida
para mí mis colegas que se quedaron era
una experiencia humana
ya estábamos en una situación que nos
recordó nuestro papel principal de
médicos y pando en metz 11 de tratar de
salvar vidas propuesto rellene
con el flujo de la pandemia el servicio
retomó su actividad de tratamiento del
dolor con pacientes un poco abandonados
durante las olas sucesivas de kobe
y nos vamos ahora hasta surf site en el
estado de florida en eeuu en donde
fueron encontrados cuatro cuerpos más
bajo los escombros del edificio
residencial que parcialmente colapsó el
pasado 24 de junio de esta forma la
cifra de fallecidos aumenta ya a 36
personas y más de un centenar siguen
bajo los restos de esta edificación los
esfuerzos de los equipos de búsqueda se
han intensificado en las últimas horas
pese a la amenaza que representa el
clima cambiante ante la llegada de la
ahora huracán
elsa de otra parte comenzaron también
los funerales de algunas de las víctimas
y tras un año de suspensión debido a la
pandemia de kobe 19 comenzó la edición
número 74 del festival de cine
internacional de cannes que reúne lo más
destacado de la industria
cinematográfica mundial 24 cintas
compiten por la palma de oro que es el
máximo galardón que entrega este
festival nuestra enviada especial a la
ciudad de khan erika olavarría nos
cuenta más pormenores de esta primera
jornada en el siguiente reporte
escuchamos normalmente se hace en mayo
pero ahora lo estamos haciendo en julio
en pleno verano por eso también hace
mucho calor y eso hace que haya mucha
gente que está de vacaciones aquí en la
costa azul recordemos que a raíz
justamente a la pandemia hay muchos
franceses que no han salido al
extranjero o se han quedado en este país
y obviamente la costa azul es un destino
de preferencia así que el ambiente está
aunque obviamente hay menos prensa y
menos festivaleros como se le conoce al
público del festival una alfombra roja
tradicional la única diferencia es que
periodistas y camarógrafos tenían una
mascarilla obviamente negra además
porque desde las 5 de la tarde en todos
los eventos oficiales santiago se pide
una mascarilla negra para que obviamente
no desentonar con la elegancia de este
festival esto en las noticias
[Música]